Siempre quise ser un cyborg.
Uno de mis programas favoritos era "El Hombre Nuclear,"
y esto es un poco parecido, pero más barato,
(Risas)
Normalmente soy muy auto-consciente, y un poco extraño,
usando esto, pero, hace unos días vi
a un renombrado estadístico tragando espadas aquí,
Así que pensé que sería aceptado en el grupo.
Pero no es eso de lo que quiero hablar.
Quiero hablar de juguetes, y el poder inherente que veo en ellos.
Cuando yo era niño, fui a la escuela Montessori
hasta el sexto grado en Atlanta, Georgia.
Y entonces no pensaba mucho en ello.
pero luego, me di cuenta de que esa fue quizás la cumbre de mi educación.
Desde ese momento, todo lo demás fue en declive.
Y no fue hasta más tarde, cuando empecé ha hacer juegos, que --
En realidad los pienso como juguetes.
La gente me llama diseñador de juegos, pero yo pienso en ellos como juguetes.
Pero comencé a interesarme en Maria Montessori y sus métodos,
y la manera en que encaraba las cosas,
y cómo pensaba que era valioso para los niños descubrir cosas por su cuenta.
en lugar de que se les enseñara, abiertamente.
Y ella diseñaría estos juguetes, donde los niños jugando
en realidad entenderían principios profundos
de la vida y la naturaleza mediante el juego.
Y dado que descubrían estas cosas, permanecían con ellos más tiempo,
y también experimentarían sus propios errores;
había un aspecto de aprendizaje basado en errores. Era importante.
Y así, los juegos que hago, los pienso como juguetes Montessori modernos.
Y en realidad quiero que sean presentados de una manera
en que los niños puedan explorar y descubrir sus propios principios.
Así, hace unos años, comencé a interesarme mucho
en el programa SETI. Y es algo así como yo trabajo,
me interesan diferentes temas, me sumerjo en ellos,
los investigo, y luego trato de hacer un juguete sobre eso,
para que otras personas puedan experimentar el mismo descubrimiento que yo
mientras estudiaba ese tema.
Me condujo a la astrobiología, que es el estudio de la vida posible en el universo.
Y a la ecuación de Drake, que investiga la
probabilidad de que la vida surja en los planetas, su duración, cuántos planetas hay,
cosas así.
Y comencé a ver lo interesante que era la Ecuación de Drake,
porque abarcaba tantos temas diferentes -- saben,
física, química, sociología, economía, astronomía.
Y otra cosa que realmente me impresionó hace mucho,
fue "Potencias de Diez," la película de Charles y Ray Eames.
Y comencé a poner estas dos cosas juntas y preguntarme,
si podría crear un juguete donde los niños puedan cruzarse
con estos interesantes principios de la vida,
como existe y como podría ser en el futuro.
Cosas donde se podría, recorrer temas
como el principio Copernicano, la Paradoja de Fermi,
el principio Antrópico, el origen de la vida.
Voy a mostrarles un juguete en el que estuve trabajando,
del que realmente pienso más que nada como un juguete filosófico.
Jugando con él, -- esto sugerirá preguntas filosóficas.
Este juego llamado "Spore." en el que he trabajado por años.
Se acerca a estar terminado.
Transcurre en diferentes escalas, primero,
desde lo muy pequeño a lo muy grande.
Voy a saltar el inicio del juego,
y pueden comenzar este juego como en una gota de agua,
como una criatura unicelular muy pequeña,
y, básicamente sólo debes vivir, sobrevivir, reproducirte.
Aquí estamos, a escala microscópica,
nadando, y ya sé que las células no tienen ojos,
pero las hace más lindas.
Los jugadores jugarán a través de cada generación de estas especies,
y mientras juegas, la criatura crecerá poco a poco.
Mientras comenzamos a crecer, la cámara comienza a alejarse,
y cosas que se ven en el fondo allí
comenzarán a entrar en escena lentamente,
mostrando un poco aquello con lo que interactuarás cuando crezcas.
Mientras comemos, la cámara se aleja y comenzamos a interactuar con
organismos más y más grandes.
Jugamos a través de muchas generaciones aquí, a escala celular.
Voy a adelantarme. En cierto momento crecemos y llegamos
a una escala macro-evolutiva.
En este punto, dejamos el agua,
y algo importante en este juego es que en cada nivel,
el jugador diseña su criatura,
y ese es un aspecto fundamental de esto.
En el juego evolutivo aquí, en la escala de criaturas, debes comer,
sobrevivir y reproducirte. Muy Darwiniano.
Una cosa que notamos con "Los Sims," un juego anterior,
es que los jugadores aman crear cosas.
Cuando pueden crear cosas en el juego hay una enorme
empatía en la conección con ellas, incluso aunque no sean
tan bonitas como las que harían otros -- como un artista profesional
de juegos -- se apegan a ellas
y se preocupan con lo que les suceda.
En este punto, dejamos el agua, y ahora esta criatura --
podemos subir el volumen -- podemos tratar de comer,
podemos espiar a este pequeño aquí -- y tratar de comerlo.
Bueno, peleamos.
Lo tenemos. Ahora a comer.
Realmente, en esta parte del juego, lo que hacemos
es movernos y sobrevivir, y llegar a la siguiente generación,
porque jugaremos a través de cada generación de esta criatura.
Podemos aparearnos, veamos si
una de estas criaturas quiere aparearse. Sí.
En realidad, no quisimos replicar la evolución
con humanos y todo, porque es casi más interesante
investigar posibilidades alternativas de evolución.
La evolución se presenta generalmente como un único trayecto,
pero en realidad representa este enorme conjunto de posibilidades.
Una vez apareados, podemos hacer clic en un huevo.
Y aquí es donde el juego comienza a ser interesante,
porque una de las cosas en que nos concentramos fue darle a los jugadores
herramientas potentes, para que un pequeño esfuerzo del jugador pueda
crear algo muy atractivo. Implica mucha inteligencia, por parte de las herramientas.
Pero básicamente, este es el editor, donde diseñaremos
la siguiente generación de criaturas. Tiene una columna,
puede moverse, puede extenderse.
Puedo hincharlo o encogerlo con la rueda del ratón, como si lo esculpiera,
como arcilla. Tenemos partes que puedo insertar o quitar.
La idea es que el jugador pueda diseñar
cualquier cosa que imagine en este editor, y darle vida.
Por ejemplo. podría poner unos miembros en el personaje.
Los haré más grandes.
Y en este caso podría decidir que voy a poner --
Pondré bocas en los miembros.
Entonces los jugadores son alentados a ser creativos en el juego.
Le daré, un ojo en el medio, lo agrandaré un poco, apuntando abajo.
Le daré unas piernas.
Básicamente, queremos que esto se sienta como
un amplificador de la imaginación del jugador,
para que con pocos clics un jugador pueda crear algo
que no pensaron que fuera posible antes.
Es casi como diseñar algo como Maya
que un niño de ocho años pueda usar.
Pero en realidad el objetivo fue, quería que en un minuto alguien pudiera replicar
lo que típicamente le lleva a un artista varias semanas en crear.
Ahora le pondré unas manos.
Básicamente armé una pequeña criatura.
Le daré una pequeña arma en la cola, para que pueda pelear.
Ese es el modelo completo. Ahora podemos ir a la fase de pintura.
En esta fase, el programa tiene cierta comprensión de
la topología de esta criatura. Sabe dónde está la columna,
dónde están los miembros.
Sabe cómo deberían aplicarse las bandas, cómo debería sombrearse,
y así, generamos proceduralmente el mapa de texturas --
y esto es algo que a un artista de texturas le llevaría varios días para hacer.
Y podemos probarlo, una vez terminado, y ver cómo se movería.
En este punto, la computadora anima proceduralmente esta criatura.
Examina lo que he diseñado, y le da vida.
Y podemos ver cómo bailaría ...
(Risas)
Cómo demostraría emociones, como pelearía.
Está actuando con sus dos bocas allí.
Puedo hacer que pose para una foto -- tomar una foto.
(Risas)
Luego puedo traerlo de nuevo al juego, ha nacido,
y juego la siguiente generación de mi criatura a través de la evolución.
De nuevo, la empatía que tienen los jugadores cuando crean el contenido
es tremenda. Cuando los jugadores crean contenido en el juego,
éste se envía automáticamente a un servidor
y luego redistribuido a los otros jugadores de manera transparente.
De hecho, cuando interactúo en este mundo con otras criaturas,
estas criaturas llegan de manera transparente desde los otros jugadores.
Así que el proceso de jugar es un proceso de construir esta enorme base de datos
de contenido. Y casi todo lo que se verá en este juego,
tiene un editor en el juego en donde el jugador puede crear,
todo el recorrido hacia la civilización. Este es mi bebé.
Cuando como, comienzo a crecer. Esta es la siguiente generación.
Pero voy a adelantarme aquí. Normalmente lo que sucedería
es que estas criaturas harían su camino, eventualmente volviéndose inteligentes.
Comenzaré a tratar con tribus, ciudades y civilizaciones de ellas con el tiempo.
Voy a adelantarme hasta la fase espacial.
Eventualmente saldrán al espacio y comenzarán a colonizar y explorar el universo.
En cierta forma, quiero que los jugadores construyan este mundo
en su imaginación, y luego extraerla de allí,
con la menor dificultad posible.
De eso se tratan estas herramientas, ¿cómo hacemos que el juego,
sea un amplificador de la imaginación del jugador?
¿Y cómo hacemos de estas herramientas, estos editores, algo que
sean tan divertidos como el juego mismo?
Este es el planeta en el que estuvimos jugando hasta ahora en el juego.
Hasta ahora todo el juego se jugó en la superficie de este mundo aquí.
En este punto tratamos con un pequeño planeta de juguete,
casi, de nuevo, como la idea de una juguete Montessori.
¿Qué sucede si le damos a alguien un planeta de juguete
y le dejamos jugar con las dinámicas en él,
qué descubriría? ¿Qué podría aprender de esto?
Este mundo fue extraído de la imaginación del jugador.
Este es el planeta en que el jugador evolucionó,
así que los edificios, vehículos, arquitectura, civilizaciones,
fueron diseñadas por el jugador hasta aquí.
Esta es una pequeña ciudad con algunos tipos caminando por ella.
La mayoría de los juegos ponen al jugador en el rol de Luke Skywalker,
el protagonista participando en esta historia.
Esto es más como poner al jugador
en el rol de George Lucas,
Quiero que, después de jugar esto,
que hayan extraído todo un mundo con el que interactúan
Desplegando esto, tenemos todo un conjunto de criaturas
viviendo en la superficie del planeta, muchas dinámicas están en marcha.
De hecho, puedo ver aquí, esta es una red alimentaria simplificada
que funciona con estas criaturas.
Puedo abrir esto y explorar lo que existe en la superficie,
y tener una idea de la diversidad de criaturas que aparecieron.
Algunas fueron creadas por el jugador,
otras por otros jugadores, enviadas aquí.
Hay un tipo de cálculo de lo que se requiere,
cuántas plantas se necesitan para los herbívoros,
cuántos herbívoros para que coman los carnívoros, etcétera,
que se tiene que equilibrar activamente.
También, en esta fase, daremos más poderes divinos al jugador,
y se puede experimentar con este planeta, como un juguete.
Y puedo llegar y hacer cosas, y tratar al planeta como arcilla.
Tenemos, simples sistemas de clima,
una geología simple. Por ejemplo, puedo usar una herramienta y,
trazar ríos.
Todo esto es como una arcilla, una escultura.
También puedo jugar con las dinámicas del mundo en el tiempo.
Una cosa que puedo hacer es inyectar gases CO2
en la atmósfera, y eso es lo que estoy haciendo.
Hay una lectura aquí abajo
de la atmósfera planetaria, presión y temperatura.
Mientras inyecto más atmósfera,
comenzaremos a meter gases de invernadero
y comenzarán a notar -- veremos el nivel de los océanos subir.
Y nuestras ciudades estarán en peligro, muchas son ciudades costeras.
Puedes ver los niveles oceánicos elevándose e invadiendo las ciudades,
Comienzo a perder ciudades.
Básicamente, quiero que los jugadores experimenten y exploren
un enorme espacio de errores -- allí va una ciudad.
Con el tiempo, esto va a calentar el planeta.
Al principio veremos una elevación global del océano
en nuestro planeta de juguete,
pero con el tiempo -- puedo acelerarlo un poco --
veremos el impacto calórico también.
No sólo se hará más caliente,
se hará tan caliente que los océanos se evaporarán.
Primero subirán, y luego se evaporarán, y ese será mi planeta.
Básicamente, lo que tenemos es tal vez
la secuela de "Una Verdad Inconveniente," en dos minutos,
y eso nos lleva a un punto interesante sobre los juegos.
Aquí, océanos enteros se evaporan de la superficie,
y si se calienta más, en algún momento el planeta se derretirá.
Aquí va.
No sólo simulamos las dinámicas biológicas -- redes alimentarias y demás --
sino también geológicas, en una escala muy simple.
Y lo que me interesa de los juegos, en cierta forma,
es que creo que podemos tomar dinámicas de largo término
y comprimirlas en experiencias de corto término.
Porque es difícil para la gente pensar en 50 o 100 años,
pero cuando les dan un juguete, y pueden experimentar estas dinámicas
en unos minutos,
creo que es un punto de vista completamente diferente, el que desplegamos,
usando el juego para re-mapear nuestra intuición.
Casi de la misma manera en que un telescopio o un microscopio
recalibra la vista; creo que las simulaciones de computadora recalibran el instinto
a lo largo de vastas escalas de espacio y tiempo.
Aquí está nuestro sistema solar, nos alejamos del planeta fundido.
Y tenemos otros planetas en este sistema solar.
Volemos a otro.
De hecho, tendremos un ilimitado número de mundos
que pueden explorar. Cuando nos movemos hacia el futuro,
y comenzamos a ir al espacio,
estamos tomando cosas de la ciencia ficción.
Y como en mis películas favoritas de ciencia ficción
quiero jugar con diferentes dinámicas.
Este planeta tiene algo de vida en él.
Aquí está, hay vida nativa allí.
Una herramienta que puedo sacar de mi OVNI es un monolito
que puedo depositar.
(Risas)
Pueden ver que los sujetos comienzan a acercarse
e inclinarse ante él, y cuando lo tocan, se vuelven inteligentes.
Así que puedo tomar especies en un planeta y hacerlas conscientes.
Ahora entramos en dinámicas tribales.
Y ahora, como soy el Elegido, puedo salir del OVNI
y aparecer y deberían adorarme como un dios.
(Risas)
Al principio están asustados.
Tal vez no me están adorando.
(Risas)
Creo que me iré antes de que sean hostiles.
Pero básicamente quiero una diversidad de actividades que se pueda jugar,
Básicamente quiero poder jugar,
"El Día en que Paralizaron la Tierra" "2001: Una Odisea Espacial"
"Viaje a las Estrellas" "La Guerra de los Mundos"
Nos alejamos de este mundo -- no alejaremos de la estrella --
una de las cosas que siempre me frustraba de la astronomía
cuando era niño es cómo se presenta siempre bi-dimensionalmente
y tan estática. Mientras nos alejamos de la estrella, vamos hacia
un viaje interestelar,
y tenemos una sensación de espacio en torno de nuestra estrella.
Lo que realmente quería hacer es presentar esto,
tan maravillosamente 3D como realmente es.
Y no solo eso, sino también mostrar las dinámicas,
y muchos objetos interesantes que pueden encontrares, como en el Hubble,
a frecuencias y escalas casi realistas.
La mayoría de la gente no tiene idea de la diferencia entre,
una nebulosa de emisión y una nebulosa planetaria.
Pero estas son las cosas que podemos poner en esta galaxia.
Volamos aquí hasta lo que parece un agujero negro.
Quiero tener un zoológico de objetos Hubble
con los que la gente pueda interactuar y jugar como juguetes.
Aquí hay un agujero negro al que probablemente no queremos acercarnos.
Pero también estrellas y otras cosas.
Si nos retiramos, comenzamos a ver toda la galaxia aquí,
como en cámara lenta. Y esta es otra cosa donde típicamente,
cuando la gente presenta galaxias, siempre son estas hermosas fotos.
Pero siempre estáticas. Y cuando se adelanta el tiempo
y comienza a animarse, es asombroso,
cómo puede verse una galaxia, acelerada.
Esto sería un millón de años por segundo,
porque hay aproximadamente una supernova cada siglo.
y tenemos esta cosa parpadeando, con esta lenta rotación,
y así es como se vería aproximadamente. Y realmente,
parte de esto es acercar la belleza del mundo natural,
a alguien de una manera imaginativa, para que puedan calibrar sus instintos
a lo largo de vastas escalas de espacio y tiempo.
Chris se preguntaba en qué clase de dioses se convertirían los jugadores.
Porque si lo piensan, tendremos jóvenes de 15 años,
20 años, lo que fuera, volando por este universo.
Y podrían ser un dios fecundo. Podrían impulsar la vida
en los planetas, tratando de terra-formar y esparcir la civilización.
Podrían ser un dios vengativo y salir a conquistar,
porque pueden hacer eso, pueden atacar otras razas inteligentes.
Pueden ser un dios comunicativo, construyendo alianzas,
lo cual también pueden hacer en el juego, o sólo curioso,
viajando y tratando de explorar tanto como puedan.
Pero básicamente, la razón por la que hago juguetes así es porque
creo que si hay una diferencia que podría hacer en el mundo,
que yo escogería hacer, sería darle de alguna forma a la gente
una mejor calibración en el pensamiento a largo término.
Porque creo que la mayoría de los problemas de nuestro mundo
son resultado del pensamiento a corto plazo,
y el ser tan difícil pensar en lapsos de 50, 100 o 1000 años.
Y creo que darle a los niños juguetes como este
y dejarles reproducir dinámicas
dinámicas a largo plazo en un corto término,
y sacando algún sentido de lo que hacemos ahora, cómo será en 100 años,
es probablemente lo más efectivo que puedo hacer.
para ayudar al mundo.
Y es por eso que creo que los juguetes pueden cambiar al mundo.
Gracias.